you
hear you can hear it
hey he
still have an external
[Music]
any
normally what I said would be pretty
abstract right you hear that for the
first time but you haven't heard it for
the first time and there's lots of less
okay
so when I'm here like
this yes yes you can do that you see yes
yes you can push but what we're trying
to do now
is I if that's what I'm going to push
with I'll use the other hand my footwork
my body work you see how so get ready
feel that pressure increase okay so
watch what I do
now pressures increase too you see so I
use my body work my footwork my other
hand work to low that pressure you see
so I don't have to go here so I load the
pressure boom she hits the pressure do
you see that you see that so that's what
we're trying to do so that's what I'm
doing here when I go here there's really
nothing on there at first cuz there
shouldn't be right so but I load it
there she hit it
boom but how I'm moving the rest of me
okay that's what we're trying to do
when your boot so up and down breath
hold and Bre
okay you're looking for a dynamic
delivery okay right go
back chill
out you heard it again okay
[Music]
all right so this this is in the
techniques so what I what I did was I'm
not going to clash here I'm going to
take her at an angle and you feel the
pressure is starting to increase on that
hand you see I take her at an angle and
then that hand can now just got got her
okay so if you look at it same thing
here you
see meaning we go boom she she H that
hand see that on the other one we here
boom she Hit That Elbow can get it she's
here Bo a bottom elbow down just none of
that matters but pay attention to what's
happening as the white spiral rotates
the x pattern right that we've
identified it will cute the young hand
that's what happens
okay you're not trying to tr her you're
just working with these pressures with
that pattern finding the pattern again
you get it
so careful when you you're not doing the
patter you're doing modern stuff because
it gets soft again you feel it's getting
soft
again so you can't just go
wherever it's never got hard again until
here's the x pattern again you see there
it is right there
so careful you're not just doing
something you're feeling
instead feeling
instead so where that those pressures
are it's got sof in you see CU I over
rotated
okay try it again the x pattern is
setting up the the Y hand that's where
the C
projection see over rotated so he got
soft that became in space and he fell
into the in space then he got heavy
okay you're over rotating every
time be calm be calm
there it
is a little over roating
so you see the the the less you bring
him onto that let's just call the X
patter the L you bring him onto the x
pattern now you got to you got to make
up for it with your lips do you see that
okay so let's try to figure out how to
do the taaki the
asiak so that I don't have to use make
up for all
my unacquired energetic value
you see with the movement of my hands to
space okay that's what we're doing try
again over
rotate so a lot of times why we have to
over
rotate is because I can't internalize
I'm going to lose
positional okay like this is oh that big
guy do you get it so we're like oh
better take him off of me you see that
but you can internalize and you just
you'll hit that you'll hit that do you
get that so by absorbing the energy
inside you letting it pass through you
you are you don't have to do a big
movement to get we're
choosing to move to the x pattern which
has some rot
but I'm not having to rotate so that he
can't B me over do you see that subtle
difference okay so you end up feeling
his weight you over rotating soft
again you you you have to
absorb to to be able to feel that so you
got to ground on the foot the projection
Foot Right let it come in and let let
that hit you until it rebounds off for
you okay pay attention it's it's not
going to be just body work we're
assuming you can internalize the young
aspect right you get that that's we've
already done that okay try it
again if we're getting pushed
off so look your arches are
your toes are poting away from each
other right going to shift my weights my
heels along the midot it's going to be
much harder okay that's what I mean
we've already done the internalizing
young aspect work so you bring it into
this real okay not replace it with this
deviation of our body okay try it again
so there's a tail sign of
the fun okay so when I I come in and the
attachment is a tail tail sign of it
such that when you have two we can all
tell you're get
surprised when you're in the alchemical
state awareness increases
not decrease it you don't have this
surprise okay you see I'm not really
even looking at them okay so try to keep
that because a lot of people
think you're looking for a
hyperfocus and you're not that you're
not trying to concentrate on something
there's just an expansion of awareness
okay which which is why you need the
other line because that doesn't function
all the time right like I told you
driving through traffic don't drive like
that you got to pay attention because
there's so many things I got to obey the
law how's my car freaking work what's
that do that that kind it doesn't do any
good to go I'm about to be hit but I
forgot where my blinker is and you know
cuz I'm driving the White's car or what
have you make sense okay but we
shouldn't see a
surprise and we shouldn't see the
surprise breath where we're holding it
and then we start breathing again okay
let's try it again we're we're not doing
fut doie but we still shouldn't see that
okay for
all right I in this kind of drone this
is like freom me like G okay they're
coming in with different angles from
different vectors all that kind of stuff
so I don't want to really prescribe it
but if you pay attention okay here's the
180 you see make sense okay so I have to
get off the
180 so I will start to move my
body at some 90° fluctuation to it do
you see that but I don't want to do that
for forever I want to
eventually
hit that pressure did you feel it okay
pressure increase on the right hand and
you can hit the
10:00 you see that there's the there's
the 10:00 projection you see that or I
can bring you towards
4:00 and there increase again and I can
hit the 8:00 projection do do you
understand that
as opposed to here and shoot for
12 one you get that so I'm doing that
every
[Music]
time what one would you say that was yep
4 and8
48 you
see you you can do those you can do
those T but on yield here
I'm starting to spin the clock around
both ways do you see that okay all this
to say that the yin hand can
yield all the way to
4:00 on what is relatively a
direct x pattern
projection okay so
hence I can do that as opposed to
you see I can as soon as you touch I can
move all the
way I can do that you get it all the
time
boom
boom you pass one on the second one okay
but you're still kind of clashing you
you're going to get out of the way first
and then you find that one okay so
that's why it's a x the one hand went to
four another one went to eight we see
that okay stop clashing on
contact
yes too far the the young hand follow
the in hand and it just getss mushy it's
an X it does not follow if the Y hand
goes to four y hand never goes to four
don't pass Six you would have to over
rotate again all the way back to two do
you see that and then you can hit the
four angle okay try it again
better watch your feet you have your
feet pointing out again your heel
[Music]
weighted it has a lot to do that you're
double pivoting
let's leave our grounding foot there and
make sure we're we're using the
grounding foot yes because there's an
energetic component to to it you see our
ultimate aim is spiritual not martial
and I need that freaking Chi to drop so
that the the ego tripartite mind drops
do you get it so you're going to go
through the the actual prescribed
technique okay we're not fighting okay
so try it
again yeah there's a lot of leg tension
there do you see and the and the
projection decreased so probably more of
it was just moving my body mass okay and
you're bigger than all of
them keep
going tension out of your lower body
we're back to
surprise good watch your feet angle
he
weighted
stay tension in the lower legs
so I can't it's so hard I you can't be
corrected in the middle of a g was it
you get it so you have to use all your
training there's a way of moving from
one point on the map to the other point
on the map I have to get the Y knee
right I single p Pivot Point all that
kind of stuff I keep my Cent my line of
gravity out from between my feet do you
see that we're not really doing that
you're kind of just constantly double
waiting line of gravity in between your
feet and all it takes is for
some a little bit of Mind
attachment that is not coincidentally in
alignment with what your UK is doing and
it all gets exposed and goes to
okay so bring all your training in here
don't milk your training okay
go this is a lot of wrong foot angle and
a lot of line of gravity between the two
feet as you're moving
that over rotating
yeah line of gravity between
can any comments
request uh once you ask me to keep the
grounding foot there to expose what
wasn't actually happening became so
clear how much my toes are trying to
compensate by grasping for the mat
grabbing the mat and of course for the
toes to flex the calves have to flex and
it it just goes up okay um but by
bringing it to the surface now we can
work on it before we were hiding on it
and let's do a side note here that's
that's the
microcosm of the Sensei dasi
relationship we're going to because the
ego tripartite mind is
functioning it's going to assert the
training that is what it does okay to
not be surprised that it doesn't and in
its personation it will hide that it was
doing that do you see and the
teacher is going to one know that
process two that mind cannot hide from
the teacher so the teacher will find the
thing make you work on that thing that
will allow you to see that thing do do
you get that it's not a comfortable
process especially when it's something
that's really got your freaking mind
okay but that's the process and now you
can work on it do you see before
whatever success I thought I had was
that uration that was unexposed okay and
now you can work on it so we'll work on
it
okay
um if you go back and what we kept
noting
was my ego tripartite mind is
functioning made evident in the surprise
and the breath holding all that kind of
stuff right the muscle uh tension
variation all that is that mind is
working okay and uh it's not going to
stop working if you have tension in the
lower body it it just won't I'm not
saying that if you get rid of that
tension that mind will stop working per
se but I'm saying that mind won't stop
working with tension in your legs so
that's got to go okay and now we can
start working on that so you could start
to feel for your teachers pointers hey
you should feel uh your metatarsal
spread do you see uh you should feel
your glutes drop you should feel your
knees become more uh articulable your
ankles more
articulable uh feel the mat sink into
the mat right all these verbal cues
right your feet should be like magnetic
boots see you got that and you you start
working all of that into what's
happening and you'll see ah eventually
my mind is not freaking out like before
okay good good observation which
wouldn't happened a while ago like what
are you talking about my feet and my
toes
right anything
else all right let's get our knives hey
so this drill is the same uh and you'll
just have a propensity to get stuck on
the on the knife do you understand
that's how that's what the knife is for
we're not here trying to do anything
else I'm working on the same stuff boom
you can disarm if you
want I don't
care but you have to do the same stuff
okay
kind pull your own weapon but you're
seasoning ad
Heering projecting you can do the
first very
your I don't
care
okay see if your knife pulls your mind
whether to use it to disarm it to avoid
it do you understand do you see how my
body is say just this fluid everything
is there okay you're going to have to
learn how to use the x pattern past the
8:00 reversing it all that kind of stuff
okay find the
X go back down m
the knife trying to deal with the knife
made it all
okay find the center ignore the knife up
did you see that
okay we heard the class
Clash we're blocking you see as the
knife has
us we're chasing the
KN no no Center teacher
wow the knife got
us W okay
so so the the first thing you have to
always do right so let's go back to this
and look at the Marshall concept she's
trying she was trying some grab
a she's trying some gravit right
whatever it is my whatever and I disarm
stick okay right you got to do that in
other words you have to have some angle
of deviation coupled with some angle of
deflection right and you have to have a
center you see you have to have a center
when you when you do that you you can't
I'm not just going here like this do you
understand so I as I deflect I have her
Center already see that and then I have
to spiral rotate the fight so that I get
into the x pattern and I can find the
projection she has her knife I have to
do the same
thing you see doing the same thing boom
whether I change or whatever doesn't
matter
the reverse
X
so she does whatever you're not you know
don't no move DP you see she touch I
touch find the center you see how weird
my posture is but I find the center and
then all of a sudden it's not so weird
[Music]
we go oh you see I I thought it was
going high look here find it find it you
see X find it again you guys
understand meaning hey don't be afraid
to break mistakes cuz right now trying
to not make mistakes is fing your mind
okay
keep the foot
still on
next too much on
it find the center pull her into the no
pull her into the
pattern i' hear her in the
pattern pattern where is
it I don't
know you know you're going to rotate
start the rotation they don't find the X
if you don't if you don't start the
rotation I would imagine it's going to
be hard to see the X
line start rotating there it showed
up rotate
her don't block the knife andhere to the
knife arm
my attention you stop her
now keep per you're blocking the
knife all right so what what what were
the the attacks that they did that these
last ones I don't I know this one was
like a this is the easiest
going let lower this is same bring her
in you see how I'm doing that yes okay
boom e that's EAS to
okay
uh let's say you do you do this one you
see that this is just out
here that's your uh
gra my WR okay that's just thatch you
see that see it right there
okay so again all all she she's going to
do whatever I'm looking at whatever
there it is find the inion points okay
whether you want to disarm or not
there's the other circle with the other
a the other
okay movement X
F
you Circle
get his face you
got you you wanted his knife can you see
that where was it in
this yes it was so uh you're coming
around like this and you're like where's
where's the knife but the knife is
spinning around the other side okay it's
better to get the circle than to get the
knife okay
go find the X and the new
projection so I you're here on the
okay the one I like is to attack the
corner and drop at this angle you see
that okay but I don't know you're here
like this so it's just the x pattern
again you see you get that right or
you're over here like this and you're
turning and you're going for your
KN you could do that too
okay but what you don't want to do is
this you see cuz that that's not the
extra where's the where's the X
line okay
[Music]
on
oh
now
come
[Music]
on all right
uh you can see how the added element is
making it more access the information
but that difficulty was in the other
drill too it's just so subtle you
probably aren't seeing it okay so this
again that this is the process the
teacher sees it teacher as a new element
to your life where you can see it now
okay got got
that um so what we're doing here
is there is a problem of spontaneity
which is solved by the same process of
your internalizing your
aspect you can't think fast enough
that's why that's my phrase speed of
life means you can't do it okay so you
cannot think fast enough you can only
commune now times
irrelevant do you get that I'm never
late I'm never early there's no U
there's no B so there's no marker in
time there's no time okay that is the
only way you can do this
stuff you have to go back to my comment
about you have to let that mind drop if
that mind does not drop such that your
awareness goes into that what I
described then in that soft
focus you'll be in a dichotomous State
there's now a you and a me and there's a
before and after and there's a early and
a late and there's a right and wrong and
now I'm F okay that unless unless all
the stars line and I coincidentally
predicted what you were going to do but
you can see we're probably only getting
that maybe 25% even on this kind of
stuff with no real aggression okay so
from the GetGo as we do our standard
drills I already dropped that mind that
mind already drops and
already it that soft focus you got that
so you got to kind of watch my my eyes
they The Gaze becomes
less relevant to what I'm doing and I
think you can see it in the in where the
Gaze is and the and the eyes so they're
not I'm not looking around do you see
that
okay and if you pay attention every time
I talk again it goes on on and off a
little okay and then once I once I start
you're going to see that I'm not really
looking at her ever okay so we're going
I'm in it
[Music]
already Okay you can do it
all right
you can see it come out a little
okay so all different movements same
response you got you got it
um because all distinction and variation
actually Le so there's no difference
between same
response different response so all could
be the same all could have been
different okay all
right let us
just understand that that's what's
happening okay maybe
observe your thinking
discriminating dichotomous line and
understand that it's not going to go
away it okay all right try you m you
have to know how to hold and how to let
go do you understand there because just
as
everything can be nothing nothing can be
everything do you understand once you
drop the
[Music]
mind that discriminating
mind there's no distinction between what
was once one side of the cone and the
other coin and the other side of the
coin which means I can do
heads what someone else would call heads
do you get that I can do tals what
someone else would call taals but I'm
not doing that do do do you get that so
don't don't pick the external
shape it's what your what is your
experience of that moment okay so you
can just get rid of them do do you
understand that the problem is when
I pick and choose and distinct get rid
of them from hold on to them and get the
knife and it shows up in our body it
shows up in our Marshall tactics you see
so you got pulled off balance you got
preoccupied with the knife what was the
other hand do it do do you understand
that they start stop traversing the mat
kazushi goes off and all all that stuff
but you you can't just let go do do you
understand is so keep that in mind okay
we're it's not that one side is wrong
and the other side is right it's whether
I'm in a dichotomous State when I'm
doing one side or the other side do you
see that or not that's the that's what
we're working on okay that's what I was
trying to show you with all those
variations of her attacks that just led
to this same freaking technique do you
see that over and over and if you start
now analyzing
for that for more uh concentric aspects
you could see the footwork was the same
The Waiting was the same the adhesion
was the same the traversing of her
Center across the mat was the same The
Gaze was the same the breath pattern was
the same do you do you see
that but yet there was a difference to
it all
okay all right so don't be AF don't
chase the knife like that that's where
we ran into problems okay
uh any comments or
questions do you have anything to share
on that experience of the ukemi on that
last one you might not I don't know well
well yeah as usual you always had my
Center where there's times when going
with SH CH
where I have a solid stance or they have
a solid stance um and so it's harder to
find the rotation because you don't I
don't have the center yeah
um probably the
most okay yeah when we start just arm
fighting okay and so in in
my in my uh understanding
of all this stuff if I if I have your
Center you have to now
fight to regain your
initiative
and that is a lot harder to
do than you had initiative and you keep
initiative do you understand that so
whatever your counter might be let's say
you love the the double leg okay if you
can throw the double leg from initiative
you're going to be very very
successful you try to throw the double
leg from no initiative you're not
getting it do you see or if you
try to have to regain initiative so you
can throw the double leg you probably
are not going to get it either I'm way
more able to counter that double leg
then in comparison the double leg from
initiative so the same thing goes with
the knife if you don't have their
Center hands arms weapons they move
freaking fast do you see that and hence
the possibility of the the internet
dread of the sewing machine stabbing do
you
see but when you have somebody
Center he he's if he throw throws the
sowing machine stabbing from no Center
control he's going to lose you see so he
has to stop the stabbing to regain his
Center well that won't be so easy do you
see that so a lot of people go what do
you do for the sewing machine you do
iido you take the center do you
see you take them into the
pattern and you find your angles of
attack on the x pattern it it doesn't
change so you're like well what if you
don't get his Center that that could be
the next question you're
disengage do do you see that you you're
not going to you you're losing you got
to disengage tly reposition and find a
new angle of attack that's how it is
you're not you don't want to
have a
technique on somebody who has their
Center
do do do you guys get do you understand
that like you're going to lose it's the
same thing when I teach the recruits if
that guy is shooting at
you that Firing Lane is
theirs Traverse across the Firing Lane
and dominate a new Firing Lane you're
not going to win shooting back on that
line of attack on somebody who's always
already shooting at you do you see that
you have to reposition establish a new
line of of attack and have him move into
your line of attack so this idea that
you can you can be so behind the udal
Loop or behind the initiative curve and
then come back like that's just not real
that's not true not freaking true okay
you're not coming back and you know my
statement trying to do that you should
accept the beating you have coming
because you up so bad you you
need this so that reality brings light
to your stupidity okay initiative
counts
um and that's what you saw like every
every
time your knife touched whatever part of
my body it was which I can't even
remember where where it
was your your attack ended up touching
my part of my body and at touch I
brought I seized the center brought it
into the Curve establish the x pattern
do do do you see that um or just kept
the curve and let the rep start over
because once you have the curve that
that's the x is easy do you see that so
once you have the seizure that's hard
right Sean you're having problems with
that's hard to out contact seiz the
center but once you have that the next
one is uh where do I set up the
curvature for the line I'm going to cut
across not so easy right A lot of times
Sean you're over rotating past that X
right but once you know how to do that
that to me the technique is is really
over the drill is over because the
spiritual aspects already happen if my
mind did not
drop in the beginning I wouldn't have
adhered and seized your Center at the at
the first Contact you see that and if I
can't take it on a curve I would have
been
contesting do you see that and so I
would have had to also know how to uh
drop the Yang aspect internalize the
Yang aspect so there's really nothing
left to do for the co that all all the
aspects of Coq already happen so that's
why a lot of times I just leave the
curve and stop the projection okay
sometimes I just make sure I can feel it
but you don't have to you're you did the
drill you did what we want out of the
drill
okay um there was one rep where I felt
my mind kick in again but it's like
everything else it's it's uh now let it
go and once you let it go that's the
skill of release all of these energetics
will reestablish themselves and you ref
find what you need to find
okay
um all right any other comments or
questions what about watching
that
um I did there was one time with
Virginia where I just watch your feet I
didn't even watch the hands I seems like
I when you talked about diffus your
awareness a bit I tend to focus on the
hands because I I don't know I'm looking
for some kind of trickery or something
some external some external thing that's
going to that I could intellectually
process and consciously choose to adopt
that'll give me the technique but this
this can't so before keep in mind what
you were going to say but did anyone
look at do you see the face gets that
kind of meditative
flexion dropping the Gaze everything do
you see the breathing pattern isn't
rising and falling starting and stopping
the shoulders aren't coming up and down
there's no variation in the flexion were
you able to see I any of that okay all
right go on so I kind of broke it down
into that CU I knew I was looking at the
hands so this time I just looked at the
feet what I saw with the feet is exactly
the same thing as every other class
every other technique there was no I
noticed in my feet which is obviously
the result of not reaching the U the GU
mine but my Feet's a lot of stutter
stepping skipping double pivoting and
yours are just single step single step
there's a whole lot happening up here
and your feet are just it it was just
really smooth yeah and just looking at
the feet there was none of that
disturbance that I feel trying to
recatch my balance that I just lost yeah
that kind of thing yeah and I I'll be
honest sometimes when I watch the video
the the feet are even surprising to me
cuz I'm I'm not watching myself out
there and I watch the video and it does
it does look
like and the foot is stuck do you know
whether it's whether you your analogy is
magnet boots or suction cuffs or it
weighs a lot the feet just stop moving
okay um but it goes back there no
flexion in the feet so the weight of the
body and the young aspect of the UK is
just making your feet heavy does that
make sense but when we push on the UK
push on the mat the opposite starts to
happen we don't sink into the mat
another analogy
okay um so adopt that as your as an
orientation as your training whatever
we're doing
ask yourself am I sinking into the mat
do I have my magnetic boots on you know
does it like boom whatever that whatever
however
your observational
mind can poetically describe what you
saw on my feet try to bring that into
your feet
okay I did see that that we did better
if you pay attention you can watch the
video later you did better
especially when you were doing exactly
what I described there with the feet
with just my presence you calmed down a
lot and were able to get more reps
without the knife pulling your
attachment pulling your attached mind do
you see that so there it is again
like copy of the teacher copy the
teacher because there is no
magic intellectually
describable physical thing that I could
consciously choose to get the results
that I saw that that's not going to
happen okay any other questions or
comments yep I mean we we touched on
this already but um that analogy of the
fight the Archer not the arrow yes so
you were fighting the Archer we were our
first concern is the knife and then we
get to go to the rest whereas no matter
what position I was in no matter where
my knife was you had everything else
yeah and just I didn't make that up
that's the old Roman legion Maxim fight
the Archer not the arrow so kind of take
that into context those people
conquered right they kicked the out
of people after people and ultimately
decided not to do it anymore is what
happened okay and then and then they
lost their Edge there but there was a
time when any time they wanted
to they they would and could and so you
got to take that to heart it's not it's
not a
marshall take it or leave it it's like
no no no no I have to figure out what
this means and that is how I understood
that Maxim in in this kind of oneon-one
sees the center everything else Falls
from there
okay very very
important he thank you